they call me the sea horse whisperer I
do 221 dives a year all right if you
went with me you and I would be the only
two people out of 50 million that would
see one that's how rare it is
[Music]
ever since I was a kid living in Iowa I
always dreamt about the ocean I am not
trained as a scientist but I've always
had an interest my name is roger Hansen
I have probably spent more time with the
seahorse hippocampus engine than anyone
else in the world
[Music]
I saw my first seahorse here in Southern
California in Alamitos Bay January 30th
2016 I was absolutely stunned I did
recognize how uniquely different the
creature was I was afraid they would
leave I knew how rare they were then so
I went down that night and built my
first biome out of sticks palm fronds
and pine branches they named it Atlantis
and they loved the sticks they wrapped
their little tails around them so I
think I just guessed what they might
like so I built two more biomes sister
communities one I called Vegas and the
other one I called the Bellagio after a
while by the numbers I was seeing they
had set up a colony and guess what if
you build it they will come it's
captured interests not just in
California but worldwide to have them up
this far up the coast is absolutely
totally rare I started to learn things
about measurement and taking good data
I've kept track for four years of all
movements all sea horses I have four
notebooks each for each year of the
study and in them I take information
like tide water temperature UV rays what
phase we are in the moon because all
these things affect the sea horses to my
knowledge I am the only one in the world
that are tracking this particular
species this way
I do not get paid I Drive probably a
thousand five hundred miles a month and
why do I do it two reasons one for
science secondly I guess it's like those
wild kitties that you feed that are in
your neighborhood I really liked him and
we developed a relationship they liked
me too I started to learn about them and
realize what a superior species there's
never a fighting
never it's just gentle beauty and when
you live with gentle beauty for long
enough it starts to affect you a great
deal to the point where I started saying
Roger
why can't you be nicer to people like
these little creatures are nice to each
other that's really what happened I
consider myself a part of the herd a
little bit bigger a lot older but yes
friends
[Music]
you
[Music]